On February 28th, 2026,
the United States and Israel launched
nearly 900 strikes on Iran in 12 hours.
Military bases, missile sites, nuclear
facilities,
one of the most devastating opening
salvos in modern history. [music]
Iran's response didn't come with
missiles. It closed a gap of water 21
miles wide.
>> [music]
>> In the weeks that followed, oil surged
past $126 a barrel.
Iraq shut down its oil fields because
there was nowhere to put the crude.
Qatar declared force majeure, a legal
term that simply means we cannot fulfill
our contracts because the world has
changed. Pakistan closed its schools to
save electricity.
The IEA released the largest emergency
oil reserve in its history.
It bought four days.
>> [music]
>> Every one of those tankers is full.
The oil inside them is worth billions,
and none of it is moving because one
country understood something the rest of
the world had been quietly ignoring.
You don't need to win a war to paralyze
the global economy.
You just need to close the right door.
The Strait of Hormuz sits between Iran
to the north and Oman to the south.
At its narrowest point, it's 21 miles
across, roughly the distance from
central London to Heathrow Airport.
Through that gap passes roughly 20
million barrels of oil every single day.
That's 1/5 of everything the world
consumes.
Saudi Arabia's oil exits through it.
Iraq's, Kuwait's, Qatar's liquefied
natural gas, the fuel that heats
European homes and powers Asian
factories, all of it funnels through
this one corridor before reaching the
open ocean.
There is no meaningful alternative
route. The Gulf is essentially a dead
end, a body of water with one exit.
Pipelines that bypass the strait exist,
but they were built decades ago and can
handle a fraction of what normally flows
through Hormuz.
Nobody built more because for most of
the last century, the strait was open.
Why spend billions solving a problem
that didn't seem to exist?
China gets a third of its oil through
this passage. Japan gets roughly 70% of
its total oil supply from the Gulf,
almost all of it through Hormuz.
South Korea, Taiwan, India, the same
story.
Europe gets a significant share of its
natural gas from Qatar through the same
water.
But oil is only part of it.
A third of the world's fertilizer trade
moves through the strait.
Fertilizer feeds crops.
Crops feed people.
When this passage closes, fertilizer
prices spike, which means food prices
follow in countries nowhere near the
Middle East for people who have never
heard of the Strait of Hormuz.
And it's not just fertilizer.
Helium for hospitals, aluminum for
manufacturing, the raw materials for
plastics and petrochemicals that show up
in almost every product on Earth.
The Strait of Hormuz isn't an oil story.
It's a civilization story. A farmer in
Bangladesh, a factory worker in Vietnam,
a commuter in Munich, none of them have
ever seen this water. None of them know
it exists. All of them depend on it
staying open.
All of it flowing through a gap one
country can close with [music] a single
order.
Every government on Earth knows this.
Every military has war-gamed it, and
nobody has done anything about it.
Because it turns out the modern world
isn't built on innovation and
complexity.
It's built on a 500-year-old hostage
situation.
In 1507, a Portuguese explorer named
Afonso de Albuquerque found a glitch in
the map of the world. He realized he
didn't need to conquer an entire region
to own its wealth. He just needed to own
the exit. He sailed straight to the
island of Hormuz and seized it. Control
the door, control the trade. The
Portuguese held it for a century.
Then the Persians and the British East
India Company pushed them out.
New flags, same logic.
>> [music]
>> If you own the door, the world has to
ask you for permission.
By the time Britain finally left,
exhausted and overstretched, two powers
moved in to fill the gap, Iran and Iraq.
Both large, both ambitious, both
convinced they should be the dominant
force in this waterway.
>> [music]
>> In the 1980s, they fought a grinding
eight-year war.
Both sides attacked oil tankers in the
Gulf trying to cut off each other's
income.
Outside navies deployed escorts. Ships
burned. The strait stayed open, barely.
What makes the geography so significant
is this. Iran doesn't just border the
strait. It controls islands inside it.
Territory sitting in the middle of the
world's most important shipping lane,
positioned to monitor and, when
necessary, challenge everything that
moves through.
You cannot secure a door when your enemy
lives in the doorframe.
For 40 years, Iran has lived there, and
they know exactly where the hinges are.
But the most powerful navy on Earth is
sitting 30 minutes away.
It has been there for decades,
specifically because of this waterway,
specifically for moments like this one.
So, why didn't it work?
The United States Fifth Fleet is based
in Bahrain,
30 minutes from the strait.
Aircraft carriers, destroyers,
submarines,
by any measure, one of the most powerful
forces ever assembled in a single body
of water.
When the crisis hit, they moved
immediately.
But the Strait of Hormuz isn't built for
a navy like this. It's a knife fight in
a dark room. Swarms of fast attack boats
blurring into radar clutter.
Plastic mines cheap enough to scatter by
the hundreds, designed specifically to
hide from sonar.
Securing the lane takes weeks.
Recontaminating it takes hours.
And even if they cleared every inch of
it, the tankers still wouldn't move.
Because the real lock on this door isn't
military.
It's one phone call in a gray office
building in London.
The moment a conflict begins in the
Gulf, underwriters review their
exposure. They raise premiums. And if
one incident happens, one ship goes
down, they pull coverage entirely.
Without insurance, no commercial captain
on Earth will sail into that water. Not
because they're cowards, because the
ship isn't insured. The cargo isn't
insured. The crew isn't insured.
There is no policy. The US Navy can
clear the lane. It can escort every
tanker through, but it cannot make a
London insurance firm [music] write a
policy on a vessel sailing through an
active war zone.
The lane is open. We have ships in the
strait.
My captains won't go through it. We'll
escort them.
Who insures them if they don't make it?
This is the trap, and Iran has
understood it for decades. You don't
need to physically block the water. A
handful of mines in one narrow lane
accomplishes most of it. Even a rumor of
mines is enough. The market doesn't wait
for a ship to sink. It panics at the
first shot.
The ships stop, and the pressure to end
this lands not on the countries involved
in the conflict,
but on the ones who had nothing to do
with starting it.
Japan, South Korea, Taiwan, none of them
fired a missile at anyone. None of them
had a position in this fight, but their
economies were running on a clock. The
global strategic oil reserve, the
emergency buffer built for exactly this
scenario, was already being drawn down
fast.
The world had enough to buy days, not
weeks.
On one side of the world, the most
powerful navy in history was sitting 30
minutes from the problem.
Engines running, weapons ready,
completely unable to fix it.
On the other side, governments with no
ships, no territory, and no part in this
conflict were watching their reserves
drain and waiting for someone else to
blink.
Nobody had a move. Everyone needed one.
At some point, it always reopens. Iran's
own economy runs on oil revenue. And
Iran's oil exits through the same water
it just closed. The leverage works both
ways. So, the crisis ends. The tankers
move again.
And almost immediately, the hard
questions about how the world ended up
this exposed get quietly set aside.
Because fixing it costs tens of billions
of dollars and solves a problem that
most of the time doesn't exist.
When the strait is open, which it is the
vast majority of the time,
the oil is cheap, the shipping is
reliable, and spending that kind of
money on a crisis that might not come
for another decade is a very hard case
to make to anyone holding a budget.
So, the world keeps taking the cheaper
option,
which is trust that the door stays open.
The countries that hold leverage over
the strait are not the countries that
depend on it most. The countries that
depend on it most have no territory
here, no claim to this water, no
practical way to change the geography.
The strait has been contested for 500
years. Someone tries to control the
door. Someone else tries to force it
open. And the world, trapped in the
middle, just watches. The tankers move
again. They always do. The geography
doesn't.